welcome
[Music]
hello everyone
lisbon becomes official today -
european green capital in 2009 wines the
path we took until it was made to the sound of
nature and now we are here on this
plane called  one of the best
portuguese athletes to start this
race
this race will have the characteristics of a
marathon but also against logic it
takes dedication, speed and focus to
reach this goal
we are a country increasingly to see in
2019 51 percent of national
energy consumption came from  in the renewed ones but
more needs to be done
portugal was the first action taken is
carbon neutrality is up to 2050 but more
still needs to be done
we recently discovered a new planet
the 2 700 of which it seems it was trying but I think
that before we look in space we have
to do more here  underground
with this green distinction
we make a commitment to the city
of lisbon but also to those who
plan to build islam and avoid  the
commitment to do more and better so
that the city is increasingly green and
sustainable and so that it can influence
other cities in the european country of the
world that also begins a commitment to
the government I will call the
Portuguese prime minister antónio
costa
[Applause  ]
good afternoon to every day good
becomes today the first city in
southern europe is to have the kind of green capital
of europe and that he needed to ask
the person about the Andean breaking wave and
wearing a lot of work from the see of lisbon
for being  the first city in southern
europe chair to stay in europe
but more than we buy one
this is said is a lesser commitment that
will be 2 good and every month and we all have
first that in the future the reality of
climate change are today
absolutely outraged and  demand
action babe
this photograph is not this is a house
percent was taken in the past and
June 3, 2019 on
this day 17 thousand square kilometers
of the two billion tons of
ice disappeared
only that this is another one without water the
straws everyone because it is a sun
ocean ceará not to kiss one day our
coast
the law is a great fire in the amazon
in australia cultural say of drought
happening any other in an
extreme clock  reality of the same there
and this renato requires reaction from the car gives him
a special responsibility for two
reasons the first one we were the first country
in the world in 2016
the objective of the unit works is in 2050
the second big for we have a big
responsibility
we are one of the countries  that has
most of its territory is exciting
only 3% our territory is land
we have known it for 97 111 years
the oceans are the main goalscorers
of the climate and we need new zealand
on
the front line to think like this and that
is why it springs up in the  next month of
june
about the cuts in both because here is
a good one from the 2nd united nations conference
for the protection of the oceans
this is a global disaster and we  s we
have to be in this global challenge but we are
interested he also stated that the law has
great principles based on data
we also have special ones in the city of rooster
the countries but only on
climate change
- I didn't like the risk of
forest fire so we can't  being afraid of
actions is at the forefront
that's why we are also the first
country to approve another one of the telephonic
2051 national energy and climate plan
fixed the set of cni actions until 2050
can be seen in the different
aspects to have sex achieve this
goal of  permanent neutrality and a
greater effort we have to make it is not in
it is not in 2040 it is even this decade with
those for 2030 because science tells
us very clearly that we still have
time but 2030 is an observer on the
planet
so if we really want  result in
2050 the great effort
may be that now this decade is
from now until 2013 and that is why the most ambitious goals
we use our plan  eta your goals
reached suddenly is that by 2030
I won't talk 2050 we will talk 2030
we until 2030 we have
50% of our missions this for
differentiating the flu if we want to make a
reference it is 2019
we still have 36% right-handed emissions
for me it is forced to  do in the next
ten years we have to look for 47
percent of the total final
energy consumption known as vavá and we have to
meet the increase by 35% in efficiency and
in the ct wilson 200 goals but these are goals that
are possible to be achieved by
we did not make new among our
emissions three times more than the
european union and the first
provisional numbers people yes but no for
last
year last year we had an even more
significant option and contrary to what
many say it is possible we have the option
of emissions
with the increase in economic growth
I am more than the european average and lowering
president and lower than the european average
now present us with results of  nothing
until its results as the
concrete ones say a great contribution from
last year had to do with public transport
with the start of operation of 700
events in high
environmental performance buses and on the other hand the
very significant production of
space prices that
significantly increased the  change to
greater use of
public transport but we have to say with five years
and so this year we will end
tax subsidies for energy production
based on the interval
we will enter Santos for the year and not even
if it rescinds tax on
energy use  based in the south based on the case
of gold or based on gas and so we
have to continue
alcides concrete we have we have two
plants to produce
day based on the brake free us until the
end of the current structure of the cats of the
year and now we already have one  big party
for the year 2021 and will be the power station
of the pega in 2023
that was the power station yes they only use the
closure of these two power stations
coal
we meet in 17% of our
missions and at night
now if we take into account the effort we have
to make by 2030 it is 37 60 00
are pending with these two
of these two coal plants and this is
important because it is essential that
people believe me I am aware
changing their behavior
this makes a lot of difference and we managed to
achieve this result that is why
the results between 200 in
simple and concrete things develop throughout
this year the use of plastic we did not
use but also 12 years the municipality
we have to  ensure that by 2030
two hundred and the water used in water
product of the representation
of wastewater treatment belts invasion and we
will be able to achieve the result
we have a smaller with advantage and still
the advantage of our climatic conditions
nowadays solar is engineer and
logically  as per our
results of the action of the environmental brigade
with the study is the natural flow but the
silva in a country  s like portugal that
contrary to what happened 10 years ago
andré carlos of solar energy with the
auction we did that's it huh last
we managed to obtain a
lower price of energy worldwide 14 years
and 76 cents for the best hour by hour
means
is that a huge opportunity of
downloading courtesy had more
renewable energy and a more sustainable life
for our study is this work that
we have to pursue and that's why
we don't want to hold back the consequences
give up and we all must set our
example we  we have a team and a set
of measures that the government assumed that
companies have 2009 are none of the
citizens nor god nor to pass on the
results and that is why we also created
to symbolically mark the actors
good to be the green capital of europe
donors want symbolic but  that are
effective
the first has to do with women
I have my own experience 1080 of the
camera what is possible to circulate is
exclusively  an electric vegetable in the
city of lisbon in the metropolitan area
from the next day many brian
all niches only if you are going to walk between
careful with electric vehicles and
child's gift so we won't try to drown in
school
I learned the symbols that the government
should give to the city  of lisbon throughout
this year but also to serve as an
example for all others to
ensure throughout this year
the official residence of são bento is completely carbon neutral
we produce uranium touches
per year we produce 85 tons of co2 per year
and we will compensate for this  loss of 5 side
kiss through the consumer constitutes a
grove garden 40 through production
technology and damage 35 through
money are shortcomings - it's a
feeling let's do this year is
fully will buy the next five
years was sent through the finance
approved why  will not contribute
long term province of the
portuguese state example came in saying
we want to give this is an example  it is the same as
always lived in that difficult one it is possible
in all buildings it is possible she
tried to unite the members of the government
asipag side of all and this change
we want to make collectively over
the next ten years
if we really want to win this battle
won the battle does not end  in the next
ten years there is already a challenge I wanted to launch
to everyone and in particular to the younger ones
we have here in the program carlota
was our first marathon olympic champion
and this care for
climate action is the same thing long course is
more than a marathon but it is  the number
of trains and take care of the pace
one thing is to say maps because time
runs against us
and that's why we have to hold on to its
truth it was international before
we all can't delay the various
sanctions areas marked the 10 also
necessary to ensure continuity
of these measures because in 2030 in 2040 and
2050 very likely - we no longer have the
same general hospital as the united nations
the number represents commission  and
the first one did not bring
the same organism and so today we start
a journey that is to continue it
is you who will try to continue and that is
why through the minister of the
environment started education
we are going to launch a great movement in
all schools in all summarize
for the signing of a letter of
commitment to neutralize beautiful in
2050 the commitment of all of each one
will receive the testimony he will
continue to ensure this
neutrality
that we do not use today to do what we
have to do
if you continue the morning that  it is
necessary to continue tomorrow
here we can be sure that the world
does not end in 2050 and on the contrary in
2050 we will have a new organized
humanity to continue to live for a
long time, the only regret is
that there is a planet earth and planet
one  touch great nursery
[Applause]
[Music]
was going to finish the ace who asked for a
very important message that in front
of the camera I walked right to  it didn't address much to
all of them
when they asked us but it was worth
lisbon's effort for a problem that is a
problem that exists on a global scale of
response and the country's problems in
young people consume from functions on a quay of
functions in the finals of
regional solutions of sanctions to
continental scale and final even the
normal scale and that is why it is very
important for us to be here
the mayor the
prime minister was present you
fell united nations stage
this all of you to guarantee we will
save customized on planet earth viva
lisbon viva  the project takes
[Applause]
the all-seeing environment and energy from the
city council of lisboa josé sá
fernandes will now deliver a box
with an idea similar to classics from the
oceans and a piece of embroidered pine
curative capital if you can see it is
sustainable do not comply inter  toxic
dragonfly
is big
[Music]
[Applause]
lisbon becomes an effort is the first
capital of southern europe is if  ing
extended with this award is a challenge
that we accept small is launched by the
executive vice president of the european commission
francis time - who calls the bank
[Applause]
[Music]
the opt 'lisbon ok with freedom nothing
mounted isboa now films deviation from
long route but fans but before but before the
clash leshan also girl just
like it so much legally ronaldo pulled from the
iMF through the work nothing more anti
fleeting team
tek the championship said uncle
got what
happened guy ritchie tangshan demand the
point before if  the blog gave blood the bread
of the mouth the biggest zone unite
nobody understood the climate and so the corn
in rafa keys at stake a long time
typical show is ué
is bad being lead to one of these planets
i am not wrong km kroes day the fire
destroy 100
days renault was an average of mass use
and the hatch how much to invest in dollar and to
be is in the end
the gas pump without breaking soldiers in
bope kennel box also saw the mother
the flight the gre nais the famous bo  until i went to
school there are chances to go out with a show
case santos laiglesia natal and singing
hymns and had a 3g wi-fi plan lei
jeans and ana tiemi of chances notw
felt electrical the first tam will
be a team
stay at home can only be  by medina
webjet didn't even have the basics if they heard
basics have commitment it won't
work from 2 pm at the headquarters in rio plays
without environment in vasco saw the history of
women's football in the media
worse made the flight to its textbook read the
book in the duck can't see it or not  11 at
night drop popularity
yuri's mother don't go dom shopping
leblon jota quest show climbed in this
team it starts well to get to this site
the car will give you the llamas
william navigation's father's day sol left
please please or shopping norte sul
plaza kite in the river in film can species
in another temple of october and saw if
so to which explicit of the wedge to
change with me
in the panel the law is worth
file instead of the feet puddle of blood
[Music]
cold in the river is 40 thousand new te  technologies
says
planet pop jumps to the site of rio show
a man of 58
[Applause]
this delivery sure comes
a box with the old need in
plastic in the oceans and the piece the boy
wants cumulative capital left 2020
all the games that come here mistakes
always unite  better than what I paid for this
viva portugal viva crazy
viva a lipo
[Music] it
was a great speech portugal here
represented by the capital wants to be
more sustainable greener
in the background we want to be like those
machines made portugal smile
urgent are environmentally friendly has  one
more specification
but we don't want to go around the corners of it
is always playing against each other
more than ever it is very very
important to join efforts so that there is
an increase in change and not a rise in
the water level as a deputy wins
one of the most influential voices in the world
in the fight against climate change the
secretary general of the united nations
antónio guterres
[Applause]
daughters dear friends no stage  crazy it's
good to make a speech again in
portugal and in portuguese and above all a
guy being able to warmly work the
moments in lisbon mayor
of lisbon and the mayors good but also
portugal the portuguese the prime
minister and the portuguese government for that
abstention was a meaning  it is
extremely important in today's world to
be the green capital of europe and they
meant it is particularly
important because this year in 2020
we have to prove that we want to
end the war that humanizable
also launched against nature and this
war that humanity is launched
against  nature a war of yours teaches
why nature doesn't stay nature
exposing irons when many times as
we have seen through hurricanes
through fires through all of the
dramatic drought in various regions of the world and
three in the points in a devastating way and
there is a certain iam  what we sometimes do
when we think we are destroying the
planet
we are not  we want to destroy the planet for
many blunders that we make the planet
continue for millions of years to revolve
around the sun
we are destroyed ourselves and
our possibility of living on the planet
and this year
and this year we will have three opportunities
to start in breaking that  cycle of the
conflict of war that we are moving
nature an opportunity the conference
of states parties to the
biodiversity convention second chance the
conference on the oceans will take place in
lisbon and the third is the conference of
states parties called COP 16 which in
classic will give the  countries the
possibility of committing to a
set of concrete measures to be
able to reverse the fact that we are
losing this battle of
climate change are three key moments
during the presidency of lisbon as
the green capital of europe in the three
battles that we are currently facing is
first we are  to lose the
biodiversity battle to a million species
that are at risk  disappearance in the
world is already said that wine there
are no vacancies in the world of the road or
seeing people the truth is that many
of these species that are disappearing
have a decisive role for our health
for our economy and for the health of the
economy  of the planet we
have to reverse this state of affairs and
we have little time but we have an
opportunity to do so this year at the
meeting that will bring together all the
states of our world in china
we have the conference on the oceans is the
battle for the degradation of the oceans
concession of the aspect  from the increase in
protected areas that has been
verified with some consistency
the battle for the degradation of the oceans
is also being asked on all
fronts at the moment
in fact they are from coastal areas in the
increase of black zones they have oxygen and
where there is no human life there is no  in the increase
in pollution and plastics in particular,
there is now a plastic zone covering
an area of the western pacific ocean that
s better than  that France,
right in the fact that more and more fishing
has contributed to this reduction,
let's say the fauna or the ocean, in such a
way, if nothing happens, we will have a
greater weight in 2050 plastics than
later in the ocean and the poles are not
strange it's easy  - we are reducing in
such a way with microplastics knot
plastics that today are no longer just a
problem of human traction through fax
we must first classic case of
research in the country no plastics
are already in the water at least they are already starting to
be in the air we perspire and  that is why it is
absolutely essential to win this
battle it is of the utmost importance portugal
acapo the use of plastics was only
used once through the girls that
the government can vote this situation must be reversed
it is necessary to bet on
oceans that were not integrated into oceans
in which  life is sustainable in
oceans in which it was called economies, one
can reconcile the
economic interests of the various countries with the
need to preserve and  this fantastic resource
for our world and with a
particular meaning for portugal which
are the oceans we have to wait for the
degradation of the oceans and then the
third moment is that I have to do
with the climate change convention
is what it has to do with  with the
creation of conditions to transform the
country's agreement into something truly
illegal in our battle against
climate change
as I said we are still losing
this battle
unlike portugal on display they
are decreasing emissions worldwide they
are increasing what is  dramatic is that
the outbreak in the major emitting countries that
these emissions are increasing
is true it is true that we are witnessing
we have had a time five years the
hottest we can have with
great probability this decade that has
passed as the biggest of the hottest decade
hot since there are records we haven't
done the last calculations to be
sure of this statement we are aspire
multiple
sane  incidents around the world with very
serious consequences in terms of
natural disasters
in terms of glaciers that disappear
at the level of corals that are bleaching
or even being completely destroyed
and especially at the level
if we combine pollution with
climate change and 7 million people
not even a year  for health reasons that
would be perfectly avoidable with an
effective fight against the commission and if
these climate changes had taken place,
it is absolutely
essential to reverse this state of
affairs and the year 2020 is essential
for us to achieve that impression,
now there are reasons to have some
optimism some hope first of
all we know exactly what we need to
do prime minister alves the
scientific community is clear
we can't let the temperature go
up one more step and it's going to the end of the
century for that we need to neutralize the
loss in 2053 I've always made a  drastic
reduction in emissions since the 1930s
this has  to be achieved but only
in debt and also in the books
this is possible and more that all the
technologies are necessary to do it
already exist and are competitive as it was
also said today renewable energies
are the most economical all it is better to
produce consular energy of the people
coal control with gas is better and
cheaper there is no reason to
continue insisting on fossil
fuels what used to be weeds are still being
recorded millions and millions around the
world is subsidies to fossil
fuels instead of giving  yes subsidies
necessary for the evolution to a
green economy that today could even and many
circumstances do without subsidies
if you don't continue to see this permanent
saw of course in support of fossil
fuels to coal or oil
moves this state of affairs needs to be reversed
this is a year  decisive to do we have
that what has been
accomplished well in these
three fundamental battles of the fla and
glorious books will go to preserve it.  tion
of the oceans and planning to be able to
reverse the logic of
climate change
there is today a mobilization around the world
that is particularly hopeful for
me
we see public opinions we have the
wind above all to organize without
everywhere because we demand that the political will
exists in order to lead  these
transformations that we see cities
organize themselves and defend the environment
defend a red perspective and
fight against climate change i
had the feeling of being
present at the lisbon chamber at
the c40 meeting that are the most
developed cities more determined is it is the
relationship  to climate action and check
which cities are available to do
everything that is indispensable like lisbon
to ensure that we can notice
climate change
but often contrary to what
happens today in portugal where we have
a government that supports women continues to
there are governments that make it difficult for
cities to act and for communities to act.  regions in the sense
of achieving a green economy in the
sense of achieving an
effective battle against climate change
and it is interesting that
we see that the often private resources
companies in the
financial sectors are beginning to be aware
that their own sustainability
depends on  go green and make and
are at the forefront of governments in relation to
what they do not know how to do to win
this battle and that is why it is very
comforting to hear the prime minister of
Portugal present the program he
presented because if something
is needed in the world today it is political will and
it's free let's be clear it's the
political will of the big emitters of the
playoffs countries that pollute the planet in
terms of greenhouse
emissions two coal-fired power stations will be
called up in portugal by 2000
3 the latter unfortunately especially in
eastern asia in asia year of the southeast
Asia and South Asia
we continue to see what I
call the country  we are addicted to coal we
continue to build coal plants it
is an essential feeling
that coal plants can be built it is
absolutely essential that this
time subsidies to fossil fuels and it
is absolutely essential
that a carbon tax is imposed on spain and that
tax can be removed from taxes that
there are or reduce taxes that exist
in particular in relation to income
from work to criminalize the pollute and the
crisis the people of Paraná and this is the point
that in portugal
when I hear the mayor of
lisbon and when I hear the prime minister
and in this battle in this battle  decisive
for the preservation of the planet but
above all for our preservation within
the planet to two factors that are
essential
the and capacity of the withdrawals has
today half of the world population 23 of
the European population will soon have 75%
and 80% of greenhouse gas emissions are
the cities that  can be the basis of our
success and she, however, in lisbon  is to
remember the effort and that in a place in this
set in a world where there are countries
with portugal is an example that was given
but in which the great powers
the biggest emitters continue to
increase these emissions and continues to
witness the need to accept the
other side  having the ball in 2050 is our
hope so we can convince
others and drag others is in the
european commitment plan in another
peruvian city in 2050 and that is why it is good to
see zouk at
this lisbon meeting committed to the
cities they will lead this effort the
government understood too
there needs to be political will to
fight global warming and a
European continent through the
European Union is willing to take the
indispensable leadership to lead the
other great powers that continues to
prevaricate and finally get on the
right path there is no winter on the path
of carbon neutrality in the  path
capable of resulting in
climate change
this is the fundamental battle of our
lives
is a battle we can win it is
comforting vira that as a portuguese and
as a lisboner and i must say that even though
we have not worked on the street for 15 years i
could never stop
increasing psychology living in a spurt living with the
light of lisbon with marcos goto spoke  it is
very comforting to come and be in lisbon
and we see good portugal and europe not
remembering the struggle for sustainable development
including for a
development that preserves human life and
preserves the planet and for a
development with greater equality and
justice among all thanks me
thinkers and scribes
I ask that I am not mistaken paulo I will
need to decide who is going to see here a
sudden
is tokyo wants to invest in the band on stage
that is necessary
[Music]